right well porn has taken a complete
left turn right from when I started
watching porn you know there was still
pubic hair first of all if you saw
anything without pubic hair on a point
it was like oh my god what is that are
you like pubic hair no pubic hair no
pubic hair yeah yeah why would it why is
that do you think that's just clean
that's what it's cleaner with youth yeah
by the way I've been by two weeks ago I
went with my wife if I can take it all
off
oh you shaved wax you aerodynamic wow
I've only done it twice but you know
what though yeah it pays off why because
my wife really likes it and things
happen in that region that don't usually
happen yes there's pathways there are
all these new pathways that when you
shave it you see the path oh you do yeah
I've never had my knees by my ears so
yeah but I will say this though the ink
I got a couple ingrown hairs not fun not
fun almost not even worth it it's just a
[ __ ] now you have to from somebody
who waxes frequently you have to really
exfoliate after you wax yeah ingrown
stone for yeah but that's not my what's
exfoli will you just take like a loofah
and you make sure that that skin doesn't
have any like trapped hairs and stuff so
you allow it to sprout to the hair that
it doesn't get stuck in there yeah I
don't think I've ever had an ingrown
hair it's really common yeah I don't
really have any the best thing on
YouTube like my obsession
oh that's good I'm so not good when you
have
I see what you're saying I think it's
nothing you should experiment
yeah you ever see those ingrown removals
on YouTube I can watch it for hours and
hours and hours it's the most satisfying
thing I've ever seen in my life it makes
me salivate Wow it's because you have
like 18 hairs in one little pore and
when they finally like pick it out it
just the hair comes out and they do this
they kind of like worm out like this
really like immediately yeah it's so
good in it so it's magnified you guys
have to watch the best thing I know okay
okay
you like watching she like that like
like Boyles being pop yeah like I like
watching a bunch of people like dead you
know what's so fun I do have a morbid
curious D from it but I don't know why
but it's like I can see watch a video of
somebody blowing his head off yeah but
could we really talked about this the
drawback of that is potentially giving
yourself PTSD without knowing it yeah
that's what I'm saying but uh but if you
watch it it depends how you watch why
don't your Gogh to it I'm just saying
like try it but it's fascinating to see
a human life that is present and all of
a sudden boom it's gone and to watch
that happen yeah in front of your eyes I
mean there's something crazy like that
um is it bud Dwyer yeah would that
happen by the way that was dead-on yeah
yeah I remember watching that [ __ ] me
up years ago yeah that was gnarly that
was a crazy I was crazy
because it was in front of people sort
of rushing out of his notes I was not
there used to be a Gore calm you know I
could see like a Thai guy got hit by a
truck
right and use watch photos or whatever a
riot yeah and I don't know what that is
about myself but I showed I told you
about wait I think we talked about with
Jordan Peele oh yeah I showed Jordan
Peele one time and a Russian guy get his
head chopped off oh he didn't talk to me
for a year really yeah it [ __ ] him up
it was like he didn't ask for it
right you know yeah check this out he
thought he was gonna show like you know
I mean a baby farting or something and
then it was like that and he's like why
the [ __ ] did you show me that you know
it really [ __ ] him up some people
don't like it I know I know so well
obviously he didn't light a year that's
pretty gnarly
[Music]